I think a lot of people know what an
executive producer is from movie can you
talk about what the role is in terms of
music yeah an executive producer for
like a film an executive music producer
would be responsible for all the music
anything that has music in it I'm gonna
have a hand in making sure it sits a
certain way it sounds a certain way
producing song as if I need to or having
somebody else produce a song as if I
need to just really making sure that
music has a uniform sound and some
continuity to it I think is the reason
you have an executive producer on the
music side otherwise you're kind of
hiring a person to do this and hiring a
person to do that and somebody else to
do that it can get a little bit sloppy
and it can also get disjointed I think
so my role in this particular film in
addition to producing I think 70 songs
was to just make sure everything on the
music end was handled properly and I was
the liaison between Mike Knobloch who's
the head at Universal of music and then
my music team and I was the kind of the
go-between for the filmmakers as well so
that was my role on this film and it's
the best job in the world you know you
get to make music every day and see it
come to life on the big screen I know
the style of music varies from your
projects I mean straight out of Compton
versus sing you're gonna have a just a
totally different feel but from what
you're actually doing is it very similar
I know the type the genre of music is
different
yeah the process is always similar
because you're trying to serve the
director and his vision and you're
trying to use the music to help tell the
story if you've noticed kind of on my
discography or my filmography I really
don't take a lot of projects where music
is just like background stuff it's like
the music is important and those are the
projects that I want to be involved in
so helping to tell the story is always
your job as the music producer and
really helping the director to realize
his vision is your main goal so whether
that's doing you know acapella music for
pitch perfect are doing like complete
urban you know hip-hop records for
Straight Outta Compton you're just
trying to tell a story and you're trying
to convey the emotion through the music
you